would you want to achieve with your
class I think that in the context of
mit's facilities the role of 602x is
that at the end you came an island to
electronics and if you happen to come in
there and you know Electronics
good enough
when I teach across I have a definition
of what I need them to be able to do
what I want them to be the thing the
other way around I think at the end of
the class
so
measuring somehow setting the scale by
where I started to some extent missing
the point if I can get across to the
point where they can do what they need
to do
isn't that sort of less objective
yeah but but for instance when you have
uh so so this gets this gets back to
like the whole question of how do you
assess different schools when kids come
into one school with way less skills
than the other do you hold them to the
same standard after one year of
instruction okay but I think there isn't
a meaning of learning as change in
knowledge not just knowledge or skills
or whatever okay so the most obvious way
to do this uh now let's see if I can go
back to here seamlessly
is is simply to whoops uh
damn
is to give a pre and post test and see
if there is an improvement and and what
you actually might do is is Define as as
people in this field do the gain to be
the difference between the score on the
final one the score on the initial one
now
there's a question of whether you can
give the same test before and after
or whether you would have to have two
tests that are carefully intercalibrated
the way the different SAT scores tests
measure a give you a scale you know from
200 to 800 that that is based on your
overall ability or overall skill even
though the questions were different
that's an important consideration and
and they use a method that I will
describe given enough time called item
response Theory where they look at the
particular at each item rather at each
question rather than at the test as a
whole instrument
okay so if you give the same pre and
post test instruction then
uh we only did that in admirv because
they didn't most people give moocs are
in broadcast mode
and they don't care what's received or
they don't have a good way to measure
what's received
um so so I'm going to talk about the
standard this is standard way of
measuring the pre and post-test and that
is to plot as a function of the
the
pre-test here
skill you the the score on the pre-test
you plot the gain the difference between
the post and the pre-test so if you
learned everything you'd be on this line
in other words if you've got
oops
now what has happened here oh I've
gotten in a different mode
uh
fact
okay now what happened there that's
pretty crazy all right
um
uh
it
okay so so if you've got 90 on the on
the pre-test the most you can gain is 10
right that's 100 and posts so this is a
line where you would learn everything
now it turns out that
many times what you see is that that you
the students lie the the classes or the
students lie on this line here with a
normalized gain that is to say the gain
divided by the amount you could possibly
learn of some constant number like 40.4
or 40 percent in fact there's a very
large study of a huge number uh well you
can think of the gain this little G as
being the fraction of what you didn't
know before the course that you do know
after the course what fraction of what
you didn't know did you learn
so here is the study that really put
this on the map especially as far as
physics education is concerned the study
of 6 000 students in I don't know 60
different courses and
what do you see here is that the courses
that were taught in the traditional
lecture presentation in other words
where the principal job or the teacher
was to present information in a lecture
or in a small class that they're they're
in the solid and uh colors and then the
the reformed in some way Active Learning
is in open
and as you can see from this there is
essentially a line here
about 30 percent where all the
traditional courses lie below that line
and most of the interactive courses lie
above that line and this was true uh
across so and this these lines seem to
be pretty straight and this is you know
someplace like Harvard where the kids
came in at 70 percent and here is some
these squares here are high schools
where the kids come in at 27 on a
multiple choice test where if they just
guessed they would probably get 20 I
forget if it's uh well it probably has
five Alternatives so they would get 20
if they didn't didn't know anything
okay
so now in our mooc how did how did we do
okay well we've got a normalized gain of
0.3 right on that line and this was on
the questions involving force and then
on the questions the questions not
involving Force we got uh gain at 0.33
and they're essentially equal within
error so what we showed here
is that uh that the there is learning in
moocs and that it is at least as much as
in a traditional course
okay
caveat two caveats one students in a
mooc are taking both the pre and the
post-test uh in an environment where
they're able to look at other resources
whereas usually in class this is done uh
you know closed-minded I mean closed
internet closed book which is really
excellent preparation for the way life
works
I mean you know I mean we really have to
ask ourselves when is the next time that
an important uh thing in this person's
life is going to be decided by their
ability to answer questions without
reference to the outside world
and and figure out how we might adapt to
that but okay so that's one category and
the other caveat is probably much more
important is about the affect in
introductory physics courses
98 of the students are not going on in
physics and they are there to get
their ticket punched
and the people in the mooc are obviously
there to learn because there's no reward
right other than the learner so that's
that's a big difference too now there's
a very significant thing about this this
study here is leaving that issue aside
moocs have been criticized widely
criticized as being great for the
professionals that take them but not
being effective for for uh people with
less skill or less preparation or blah
blah blah okay so what you see here is
that our mooc was big enough that we
were able to get data points for a lot
of different classes
and uh so one and two there's the
physics teachers uh and and reassuringly
they're actually the uh the the most
informed to begin with
uh and back over here is four nine and
six uh four is that they don't have
college calculus but it's a calculus
based course
they may have high school calculus but
they don't have college calculus
six is they don't have a college level
Physics course
and nine is they have a high school
education or less
and there's obviously no evidence that
students
that those cohorts are learning less
than anybody else
it may be that there is less
retention of those students I know that
was true in the Colorado mooc I I don't
think it was seriously true in in our
mooc because over half of the students
who finish the second assignment
finished the course and got certificates
and I think that's a much better measure
of of attrition or or persistence in a
mooc then the difference between the
huge the millions who come in and
register who may not a third of them or
quarter of them won't even do ever do
anything in the course
it's much better it's just like when I
teach you an elective course on campus I
know that that the students are taking
two or three courses for that that
elective slot they have left over
they're taking a couple courses the
first week and then they're going to
decide the second week and it's they're
not really my students until they've
until they've handed in the second
assignment
and so we see retention we see from
there on we see retention rates above a
half and in the course that we taught
specifically for teachers 75 of the
people who who were satisfactory who did
a decent job in the second assignment
passed the course and got a certificate
okay my Dean would be happy with that if
it happened in an elective course on
campus
if 75 percent of students who who passed
in the second assignment uh passed the
course with a C or better
and didn't drop it or anything like that
okay so that's about what I want to say
for those two uh cohorts and now I want
to little mention a little bit about
item response Theory I did before
the idea of item response Theory
is that you can look at each item and
independent of which questions are asked
uh
um and in you can determine a skill or
an ability for the student yes you had a
question yeah
the the pre-test post-test gain uh plots
that you showed and uh challenged you to
to challenge the the validity of the
pre-test and post-test questions as
really measuring learning
because you put you put up this this
Grand question at the right right at the
beginning how do we measure learning and
to what extent do you think are pre-test
and post-test questions flawed or don't
capture the whole picture of what we
would like to capture as I never said
they did
he said and I said these are conceptual
tests and and so the definition of of uh
I mean in physics this was one of this
was the tremendous revelation of the
past 20 years of education research was
that students can solve a problem like a
dump truck comes along bangs into a
sports car and uh and they stick
together and they go sliding across the
intersection which has a coefficient of
friction point three how far do they go
given the initial speed of the dump
truck and the masses blah blah blah okay
we didn't we're not asking that
answering that kind of question we're
not asking that kind of question and
these concept tests what we're asking is
uh did the force that the dump truck put
on the sports car was that greater than
or equal to or less than the force that
the sports car put on the dump truck or
can't you tell from the information
given in the problem that that's a
concept question
yes there are multiple choice
I teach a very large movie about things
I always see gains on multiple choice
tests just because the students are
smart enough not to choose the same
answer again
so how can you really measure learning
in a situation like that okay why did
every single uh
traditional course score less than 23
percent
if the students are smart enough to
learn the answers
that they only got 23 percent of what
they didn't know on the pre-test correct
on the post-test I mean this is okay I I
don't want to answer my question
there there is some evidence and about
about
an example I could give you a true false
false and I'm confident you can make 100
out of a second try
okay I'm confident I could give you a
true false question exam and then four
months later I can give you the same
exam and you will not get a hundred
percent
but we're not doing that that's the
pre-post test you you give one at the
beginning of the course and the other
one at the end
tell me what you're saying is that
you're trying to have a pre and process
that are measuring the same Concepts
it's not that you're repeating the same
question no we repeat the same question
there's a lot of data that that doesn't
matter we find a decay of about two
weeks
in in giving a test a weekly test and
then putting that question on the final
that does
okay yes
my background is actually annotational
measurements and
um
what I've been doing recent ly recently
it's really interesting that you're
talking about game scores which are part
of this bigger family of growth of
growth measures
my question to you is
about the gain score which is
recognizing the education measurement
Community is
probably the least effective way to to
measure growth however all of the other
ways are extremely complex and most
faculty are not likely to spend the time
possibly the money for the software to
do that
can you talk a little bit about the
challenge that are you gonna can you
talk a little more about different kinds
of growth that there are or the reasons
for for using game score oh
they're probably justifiable reasons
so I'm using green score because it's
widely accepted it's as you say it's
fairly straightforward to do and it's
interpretable in terms of a lot of other
background however flawed the method is
uh I personally think that the that the
Restriction to concept questions is more
serious than than any criticism of the
method
um and so now I'm actually going to talk
about item response Theory uh as a way
as a different way of measuring growth
um unless I have to tell you what it is
it's basically sophisticated grading on
a curve
um
and what you what you determine by a
pretty much a Bayesian method is the
student's skill uh and and how it fits
on the gaussian curve or the
approximately gaussian curve of the
whole class
now
um
and it it actually extracts more
information than the classical tests and
we use it in two ways as an alternative
way to analyze the pre-post results uh
we just standardize the the post test
IRT uh parameters and then we use that
to measure the skill with the pre-test
uh lots of the same criticisms apply and
then we used it to measure relative
Improvement and I'll explain what uh
let's see which is what's the next curve
here it doesn't have enough resolution
oh yes this is the curve of showing the
the skill gain in standard deviations
and for those of you who who know you
should get about one standard deviation
in a normal class and we're getting
about a half or a little less than a
half
but I have to tell you that that the
effect size depends on the standard
deviation of the class and the moocs are
twice as wide as our class at MIT or on
this on the same scale our class at MIT
is half as the standard deviation wide
and also one standard deviation below
the average of the moocs
okay but the point here is that all the
students in this class in this mooc
independent of their initial skill level
learned about this had the same amount
of skill game
okay so uh
so I just want to emphasize that using
either IRT pre-post testing or the
standard normalized game pre-post
testing method we come to the conclusion
that contrary to what a lot of opinions
have have been expressed about moocs
that we see that none of the various
cohorts we studied showed significantly
more or less gain than the others the
high school students versus those with
Advanced degrees the people who had poor
prerequisite preparation or the students
with low initial average skill
um
and so that's that's the take-home
message from the pre-post testing and
this is actually an interesting figure
the blue is uh is the overall class
distribution the yellow is the physics
teachers and just hopefully your kid is
not in one of these guys classes and
then the red is the MIT students who did
about 70 oh no sorry
200 and about 250 out of 408 of the same
questions
and so you can see their skill is less
and you can see that the distribution is
narrower
now we had in our course 408 questions
which is a lot and so every week we have
40 questions now most of the students
you have to get 60 right to get to pass
so most of the students didn't do all
the questions but they did a lot of them
and certainly with item response Theory
we can get a valid skill each week for
the students
uh
okay
oh this is not the curve I thought it
was
um okay so we can get the valid skill
and then here are the skills of several
different cohorts
there is at the top here the physics
teachers
then the people who had the MIT
math-like background and then the blue
is not physics teachers and these are
our MIT students and you know I'd like
to believe
these are actually students at MIT
who had failed the course in the fall
and were taking it again in the spring
uh so some of they may have had a little
bit extra skill here so that may may
make this a little high and of course we
may say it's going up at the end but
basically we don't see a big effect uh
from our uh from our interactive class
at least relative to the mooc students
just remember though that the MIT
students are the students who've already
failed this course once they are not
enthusiastic about actually learning
this course they just want to pass
okay so now let me switch over to moocs
and
oh no this is this is the this is the
relative Improvement
so this this shows the week by week
skills of a particular student
um and this the student has uh there are
two kinds of data here that the solid
points are the homework and the uh the
asterisk points are the quizzes and we
see no difference between the homework
and the quiz but I have to tell you that
the quiz was was open course notes just
the way or open world just the way the
uh the the homework was and also there
was no time limit because the edx
doesn't currently have or at least
didn't last summer have a time test
utility and so not too surprisingly we
don't see any difference between the
quizzes and the homework and we can
throw them all together and do one least
squares fit to them and the derivative
of this is telling us how that student
is changing their relative skill or
their skill relative to all the other
students in the class so we're looking
at the bell curve and we're looking at
each week so you can sort of think of it
as
and then we're looking at students who
start low and get higher start high and
get low they would have positive or
negative relative Improvement and this
gives us another measure of growth
so um
I just want to uh
show you the the the diagrams of where
students spend their time in these
courses and this is relevant because it
has to do with what resources there are
in the course
now
eight mrev are our
physics review course
has well problems up the top right
checkpoint questions which are
intermixed it is based on an e-text it's
not a video course this was really
designed to be blended with our
on-campus in intensive problem solving
in groups uh classroom the flipped
classroom I guess you call it now
and this was the material that we
designed to prepare them for that class
and and also uh to to do some of the
homework uh and so you can say this is
this 55 oh yeah and then there's the
e-text and then there's a time that they
spent uh in the discussion and and the
actually the way that they actually work
is that the students when they're doing
homework problems they go to the
discussion if they're stuck
and so the way we record the time is
probably not the way that that I think
as a teacher you would normally record
the time what I mean by that is a
student a student is here a student
opens a problem they they have a
homework problem they can't do it they
they open their book and they read some
in the book and then they discuss a
little bit with their colleagues and
then they come back and they answer the
question we charge all the time that
they between when they read the book and
when they went to the discussion group
as book time as e-text time and all the
time between when they went to the
discussion and when they come back
having answered the question
as as discussion time even though they
may have spent a large fraction of that
after they went to the discussion
actually working up a solution a piece
of paper
so this this underestimates the amount
of time that they spend uh actually
doing problems or answering checkpoint
questions if you just threw in the
discussion you'd probably have a good
approximation to the fraction of time
that is spent on assessment activities
and uh
now in 6002x
it's a standard course
in the sense that it is a on-campus
course traditional on-campus course put
online it has a lot of resources it has
the primary instructional medium that is
used by the students is the lecture
videos
there is the discussion and then in warm
colors as as before there's the homework
the lab and the lecture problems the
problems that are inter intermixed with
the lecture
um
it also has it has a textbook and it has
a tutorial as well as the discussions
okay so now let's see
okay so now another discussion
what one of the great things that has
that has drawn me to orient my research
group towards uh away from the homework
tutor mastering physics that was our
first big effort and towards the mooc is
the possibility that in the mooc we have
almost a complete snapshot a record of
what the students do not only
uh well not only just what they're do
you know not just the problems but the
discussions that they have the
particular discussions that they have
how much time they spent the on the on
the e-text which page they read
associated with which problem I mean if
we wanted on campus to determine how
long
student Armando here uh spent on while
he was doing problem three in his
textbook on page 237
I can't imagine any way of determining
that that wouldn't be considered highly
intrusive
we put a little camera in his room
you know monitoring everything that he
does that's what we'd have to do but in
the mooc we have the data and the
students in the in the on-campus
environment the students have office
hours uh they have study groups they
have upperclassmen who are majors in
that topic and they can get help from
all those that we can't monitor that
again without being extremely intrusive
but in the mooc we can see all that and
so my question to you is what Student
Activities which use of these resources
do you think
correlates with skill or with learning
so I'll just go back here and show you
the typical thing
okay what do you think students do who
learn in the course by our definition
either the pre-post test or the
week-to-week Improvement relative to
their peers
what can
getting tested well is homework okay is
Hope
sorry I'll move both up at once is uh is
doing homework uh getting tested
if it if they need to do a good job on
it to pass the course sure okay that's
what they do have to have to get the
right answer
the methodological question and uh
methodological question and answering
what will the week to week say
so as you said with the IRT analysis
it's sort of grading on a curve where
the average performance is like a Theta
zero so if everyone benefits from
discussion that is everyone learns
equally won't it show that there's no
learning week to week yes that's right
the relative Improvement I mean we know
from the pre-post testing that the that
the tide is coming up but but the
relative position relative to the water
level can stay the same and you're still
learning right but yes that's right but
methodologically there still is some
activities are more effective more
better use of your time others not so
effective uh I mean you know which of
those do you think will correlate with
learning I mean maybe you could just say
the total amount of time you spend
right
okay so doing problems was one thing so
I guess what I'm wondering about the
correlations is how do you in your
analysis account for the fact that
students get to choose which activities
they participate in so the students who
participate in the discussion for
example might be very different students
event what you see is in correlation
with discussion it might really just be
that bad sense of students are different
same with the problems yes there's so so
you you have come to a a critique what I
regard as a critique of this line of
research okay what we're going to do is
look for something that the students who
do that
get better you know learn more okay and
so we've agreed what learning is and we
can agree that this cohort these
students who have these characteristics
in terms of how they spend their time or
whatever uh they learn they learn more
now what we haven't established is that
that that true that that if applied as a
treatment in an A B kind of experiment
would in fact cause the other students
who chose not to behave that way to
learn more as well
okay and this is uh I totally accept
that and I just told you the next item
on the agenda which is to do where it
was this summer we're doing a b
experiments where we're different
instructional
things are being applied
um
okay but still okay so we have doing
problems uh gee I mean around here this
The Faculty are so concerned that the
students read the book and that they
read the book before they come to class
nobody said read the book
okay
a couple people think that would be good
yes
discussion would be would be good
okay so we also have uh oh all right so
I'll show you uh I'll show you the
results
um
it's interesting that
okay I think implicit in this whole
thing was that the time on task would be
a measure right we spend more time
you're going to learn more
secondly uh do you think initial
learning maybe if you know more if you
believe in constructivism if you know
more when you come in you should learn
more
that is in fact it troubled me for a
long time that the normalized gain was a
constant
why was that why is the normalized gain
a measure that seems to be constant
across a lot of core a lot of different
classes or across a lot of individual
um
individuals in one class
why should everybody learn a constant
fraction of what they don't know
especially if you believe in in
constructive theories of learning you
would think that the students who have a
higher initial skill would have more
reference points to tie the new stuff in
on
in fact we published a sort of
mathematical model very crude of memory
learning
and the memory learning and and then of
constructive learning and the memory
learning was simply defined as the
amount the probability that uh that when
you're exposed to something new you
learn it is independent of everything
else just certain memory Works a certain
fraction at a time and the other model
is that that your chance of remembering
it is proportional to how much you
already know to your pre-test score
and so the memory model gives constant
normalized gain
and I'll explain to you very simply why
that is
I am a bar graph
and this is the pre-test and the white
here is what I know
and the orange here is what I don't know
and now I go to a lecture
and the teacher loads up a lot of paint
nugget a lot of knowledge nuggets in a
Canon and blasted at the class right
that's the lecture
and the the Canon is filled with little
paint balls and the paint balls are
white
okay so now when the paintballs land in
my pants
except from the dirty spots uh then it
doesn't matter
but when they land on the top on my
unknown then does it then they cover up
a certain fraction of that
right because it because if I have uh
I'll if I pull my shirt Tails out and
have more space then these guys will
increase my my knowledge at the on the
post test and it turns out that is the
model the memory based model fits
constant normalized gain
I'm not saying that that
that in fact students are learning won't
buy memory when they do better on these
concept tests but I do have that
suspicion
because there's not a lot of research
that shows that learning that doing
better on the on the concept tests is
correlated with doing better in the in
the standard end of chapter type
problems
in fact if you look in Missouri's book
on peer instruction he has one graph
where there's clearly essentially no
correlation another graph showing
somewhat positive correlation
um okay it could be initial knowledge it
could be study habits nobody mentions
study habits you know there's all the
learning research that shows that that
uh that you can learn more if you you
learn better if you spread out rather
than just cram in before the the tester
before whatever okay so let me just get
on to the to the data here so
um so I'm going to look at weekly
correlation weekly Improvement and Gain
uh
and uh and and I'm also going to look at
at gain both so these are two two
separate things and and just start off
correlating them with the time
spent on these various activities and so
I'm going to get a lot of data presented
to you and I'm going to visualize it as
follows you know you start here from
zero and if you have positive gain you
go around clockwise and you color that
in blue and if you have a negative
correlation coefficient you go around
counterclockwise and you color that in
red
uh oh uh yeah okay so now I'll show you
uh well just remember here's 8 mrev
there's the e-text there's the
discussion there's the problems there's
the checkpoint questions
and that's it okay so now here is the
gain on the top line the pre-post test
gain and then here are the various
activities the checkpoint questions the
discussion the e-text the problems and
the total amount of time and for the for
the pre pre-test post-test gain all of
these things correlate positively with
coefficients 0.2.25 which means that
we're explaining something like six
percent of the variance which is not not
very good in mastering physics where we
had a much more tutorial type
interaction with the students on the on
the MIT final exam the correlation was
it was about a half
um
okay uh
so now we can look at we looked at two
variables here that are closely related
the average skill that the student had
and the initial skill
um
and you see that there's correlation
across the board there and then we
looked at the relative Improvement
and that is the Improvement measured
with IRT on all the questions in the
homework and in the quiz each week
and some of those questions a
significant fraction of those questions
are basically concept questions maybe 30
percent but most of them are are
analytic answers uh or or the multiple
choice of analytic or symbolic answers
um
and so
so this is this is the this is the
result it's not as dramatic as I would
hoped uh you know I would like to see
that really reading the e-text didn't
help at all
uh and uh and getting uh you know maybe
doing the problems or doing just these
checkpoint questions in the e-text
worked better I would say that it looks
as if the checkpoint questions here if
you look at each column the most
positive one the one with the most
positive correlations is the checkpoint
questions
uh and I don't know if that's an
artifact of the way we measure or if
that is actually uh the best use of
students time because it means they're
reading the textbook more uh more
interactively
okay so now let me go on and uh and do
the same thing
for uh show you the data for the
division of time among the various
resources of 6002x and remembering
there's the homework and then there's
the lab the lab was an authentic circuit
simulator activity and you had to design
a circuit that would do some such and so
a thing
um
okay and then there's again as a
discussion in the lecture video and so
on so here's the result
see a lot of red there
the categories aren't exactly yes yes
the lecture questions are are like the
checkpoint questions their their short
questions interspersed in the lectures
okay well I was actually pretty blown
away by this we're seeing correlation
coefficients approaching the half
but they're negative
okay so now
um so let's just take a look at at those
here we have the home these biggest two
here negative correlations with the
homework and with the lab what this says
is that the more time you spend on
homework
the more time you spend in in this
authentic activity lab
the lower is your skill
happy with that
yeah
okay so now just now what
what do you think is happening
if you are having difficulty with your
skin it takes you longer to do the
homework absolutely absolutely in in all
the work before that we've done we see
very strong positive correlation between
time on mastering physics or time uh on
whatever and higher skill okay
in this particular case uh in a mooc you
have this tremendously wide distribution
of initial skills and and the the
certificates are given to people who
earn more than 60 credit if you're a
professional electrical engineer you can
go in there and you can solve these
circuit problems quickly
in fact they actually learned they
earned a little bit more score
it's interesting that the score here you
just pile up the points you know it
helps to watch the video because then
you do the lecture question so these are
highly correlated
and it helps to do the tutorials as well
but that's for total score on the course
and the reason is the tutorials were
very much oriented towards helping you
do the homework problems
um okay so that so I think I think that
uh
we understand why students who spent
more time on the homework have higher
skill
I'm still upset by this line here if we
look at the relative Improvement well we
don't see much correlation between
relative Improvement and what students
do
how they spend their time
but those correlations that are colored
are statistically significant
um and it's pretty clear there are a
number of negative correlations that are
statistically significant
so we're saying that there's a negative
correlation between how much you learn
and how much time you spend oh how much
you learn relative to your peers and the
time you spend or that I mean you think
of it you can think of the correlation
either way it's just a and b are
correlated you don't know if a causes b
or B causes a or C causes both A and B
um so I don't have a ready explanation
for this and maybe somebody does Chris
are you yeah yeah so the different
cohort analysis you only did for eight
Emerald I mean that's right that's right
maybe you would find that the
normalized game was a lot less for the
weaker cohorts in this course
um and they spend a lot more time yeah
uh so so right we we have not done
exactly the same research in these two
courses and so we don't know in the
6002x about the different cohorts and
unfortunately a lot of the sampling
survey data at 6002x was done it is
called Matrix sampling we only sampled
10 of the kids I mean if you have 10 000
people in your class and you want to
find out what fraction of them come from
India you don't have to ask all thousand
to get a pretty darn all ten thousand
you just ask a thousand well that's
great but if you want to do these kind
of correlations then then just having a
tenth of your class know what country
they come from or what cohort they're in
that that's pretty bad
and uh and then maybe it's a combination
of two different cohorts and then
there's only one percent that you've
asked and so anyway so that's part of
the reason we haven't done that research
and the other reason is because uh you
know we don't have a very big group
and and the way that edx works now you
need to have a data Miner to to actually
get the data out and really make sense
of it and then you need to have a
psychometrician to do the IRT and other
stuff and then you need to have a
learning person to run the mooc and to
put in the A B test and we're just a
little bit thin but
we're hanging in there so I don't really
know I don't know why there are these
negative correlations
between how much between the relative
Improvement and the time spent
yes
do you know the correlation just in
general not
be relatively
crucial performance because I'd expect
that there will be a negative
correlation between those sort of by
definitions you start at the very right
of the bell curve it's really hard to
move farther to the right
so
okay okay so you're getting it at a big
issue in a lot of these things which is
which is uh what is it called
um a regression towards the mean
and we compensate pretty much for
regression towards the mean because we
look all the way across the whole course
and we look at the slope
it there still can be some noise in that
that that affects you but it's not as
bad as just giving one pretest and then
looking later
a pretty small coefficient so it it's
conceivable that that's I mean I I just
I'm just skeptical when you do a
correlation and it's and it's Point
0.07 it may be statistically significant
but it it it there can be so many other
cofactors that that I that I don't
believe it when I see 0.45 or 0.25 well
I that there's something there
um yes oops no I didn't do that
um have you run these statistics on any
other courses I.E are these results
content specific
or is because I think the question we're
trying to ask is does the intervention
of a mooc
uh create learning what however we're
defining that in its participants and so
my question is whether or not this is
specific to your domain or if it's
transferable across all of the different
Loops oh I think there's a big
difference between the different moocs
and uh I mean why in 6002x do we see so
many negative correlations negative 0.45
if you look at the same place in 8 mrev
you see plus 0.25 plus 0.25 that's a
pretty big difference
uh and uh we don't know maybe we were
more successful in awrev restricting the
skill of the students I mean there's
just so many factors that that I don't
know yes I think your question points
amook is not a mooc is not a mooc I mean
there's good good forces and bad courses
there's good homework questions and bad
homework questions there's good of all
of that stuff so just to to say that you
becomes very difficult to compare
between horses because they're just
unless you're controlling for the
instructional design and you're
confident that they're they're all
created to a similar level
right so there are too many confounding
variables so at the risk of being blown
out of the auditor I I would suggest
that we're actually asking sort of uh
incorrect questions right which is it's
not necessarily about the mooc per se
it's not about an open educational
resource there's a lot of data about
right it's really about how we're using
the tool and how do we measure learning
so for instance I actually live in a
professional environment and teach
teachers to teach in a medical setting
and and so to me my outcome measures are
does their behavior change around
information meaning if they participate
in this mooc or if they participate in
an online educational experience will
their practice patterns change will
their behaviors change and so that you
can use sort of Downstream assessments
and it's not necessarily how much time
they spent on the video in the mooc that
will provide evidence of what they
learned uh yeah do you have a question
yeah that's the article showing that the
testing is a very effective way of
review
practice
it explains why you just spent a lot of
time on the homework you're not going to
get anywhere but also to build on with
this
really
lends itself too well but then why
they're doing poorly on the homework
like for those now that where they'll
let where the lecture question is not
preparing well with homework I don't
know I'm just curious about the success
in one area and
follow me yeah I mean I think I think
that the implicit message of the
roadrager paper is that you do better to
keep putting all these questions within
the e-text or within the video and I
think the moocs are are using decent
pedagogy in that respect but but largely
I I feel that that most moocs are are
digitizing the dinosaur you're starting
by digitizing the dinosaur of
lecture-based Education and I call it a
dinosaur because most education people
agree that lectures are a very
ineffective use of students time and
that there are many interventions that
are better and the Hague study is is one
of the classic studies to show that yeah
the same move with different potentials
the okay I agree with you and and we're
torn between going back to later
versions of 6002x and waiting to the end
of this summer when we have our second
mooc uh that's similar to one last
summer okay I don't have much well I
don't have any time left but I want to
show you what really converted me to uh
believing in a lot of this education
stuff
uh
and uh
look okay
you know I started this like anybody
else who's a very popular well-respected
teacher uh thinking that I knew how to
teach and so I made mastering physics
and I learned that it okay well I'll
tell you what I learned it's a lot like
quantum mechanics where I am an expert
and in quantum mechanics one of the
lessons is that there is no reality
until you measure it and that your
measurement affects the result and I
would say that's true in education it's
only worse okay
okay so what really and one of the big
things that we did was to show how
deleterious copying your master in
physics was in terms of your final exam
grade negative 0.47 correlation blah
blah blah and then we looked under the
hood and we looked at the two kinds of
questions on the final exam the symbolic
questions and the conceptual questions
and what we plotted here is the uh the
we could measure the amount of symbolic
homework that was copied and we had a
and we just about all the students did
the early questions which were the
concept questions on the homework
assignment and so we actually got a
normalized gain of around 0.38 which is
pretty good but I think it's because of
the interactive nature of mastering
physics okay
but now here's the problem
here's the problem
uh if we look as a physics teacher we
have expectations the students start
symbolic Problems by conceptual
reasoning right you figure out what
physics principles apply and then you
write down the equations
now this conceptual test here these this
Orange Line Orange fit that also that
test had about 40 percent numerical
questions on it physics problems that
you know you're used to hold the swing
up here and you let it go how fast is it
going at the bottom
um
well we teach students and and all you
know we teach students to solve the
thing symbolically and then plug in the
numbers
if you did that you'd be a lot better
at a at answering the numerical
questions and yet there is no
correlation here and there is a
tremendous correlation here on the
symbolic problems this is 2.4 standard
deviations there's two effect sizes 2.4
from this one intervention namely doing
your mastering physics homework
on okay so now I just really have
thought about this a lot the problems
cover the same topics
and so this is by the normal physics
expert teacher expert physicist who is
also a teacher unexpected and I really
think it gets back to the comment made
about assessment
uh
students are not experts and basically I
think we're only teaching them to answer
our examinations at least in these
service courses and I don't like that
conclusion but I'm pretty much driven to
it and and that's the end of my talk
cool
and I guess we have a couple minutes for
discussion so I I I'm sorry I actually
think that we are already in lunch time
and we are sorry
um
Dave is here you can come in ask him
questions offline but who we have
already started serving lunch outside
okay